- Y'all, let's finish up with something
we came across on social media.
This is "What I'm liking."
(upbeat drum music)
An attorney turned pasta maker.
That's right, that's what I said.
Is sharing his secrets to
creating some of the most
colorful and interesting noodles ever.
He makes everything from ravioli
to lasagna soup, all from scratch. I know.
Check out TikTok's Danny Loves Pasta.
- [Danny] Last year,
my lasagna soup videos
got almost a hundred million views
and now that the weather
is getting colder,
it's time to bring it back.
Lasagna soup is basically
a deconstructed lasagna.
And if you remember, we call
this the sizzle lasagna soup.
(audience applauds)
- My mouth is watering.
That post combined got over
a hundred million views,
so people are into lasagna soup
is what we have figured out.
Now Danny has a book out
called "Danny Loves Pasta,"
and we have him on the line
watching on NBC New York.
What's up Danny?
(audience applauds)
- Hi Kelly, thanks for having me.
- Well, thank you for joining us.
So how does one go from
lawyer to pasta expert?
- Well, pasta has always
been my favorite food,
and when I was growing up,
my grandmother was this
amazing Italian American cook
and she would make these huge feasts,
and I'm kind of embarrassed to say this,
but I was a very picky eater,
so I would always only eat
the pasta she would make.
And she would always make
fresh pasta for Christmas.
So in 2020, my husband and I
had just had a newborn baby,
so we couldn't go home for Christmas.
So I was like, "I'm gonna
learn how to make fresh pasta."
I made her fresh pasta. I
called her, she loved it.
But unfortunately,
shortly after Christmas,
my grandmother very
unexpectedly passed away
and it was very, very hard on me.
I had been so close with her,
so I just kept making
pasta in her memory to try
and keep her memory alive
and to feel close with her.
And it kind of just snowballed
from there very unexpectedly.
- Oh, that's so beautiful.
So how did you get so good at it?
Just practice?
- Practice, practice, practice.
I started with her
recipes, and then I sort of
took it in a different direction.
I use all natural ingredients
like spinach and beets
and turmeric to make a pasta
in every color of the rainbow.
Now we have a 3-year-old daughter
and a three-month-old daughter.
So my older daughter likes
to be in the kitchen with me,
so I'm always making shapes for her.
I make cute pasta that
looks like her favorite
cartoon characters or flowers
or plants or unicorns or rainbows.
So hopefully one day she'll be making
pasta in the kitchen with me.
- Oh, that's so cool, man.
That's so cool. You're doing this.
The time you're spending with her,
but also teaching her how to
really cook yourself a meal.
I wish I knew how to really
do that, but I can Postmates.
Thank you so much for joining us.
This is so cool and it's so beautiful
that you're carrying on
your grandma's legacy.
Everybody pick up Danny's
book, "Danny Loves Pasta"
wherever you get your books.
Thank you so much, Danny.
I'm liking your post right now, all right?
(graphic pings)
(audience applauds)
All right, and that's not all.
Our season-long partner
Pilot, pen makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show" want
to honor truly unstoppable
people just like you, man,
so they're gonna be writing you a check
for $1,000, how's that sound?
(audience applauds)
- Thank you, Kelly.
- Thank you, Danny.
And thank you to all our guests this hour,
Jennifer Garner, Tony Gonzalez,
Billie Dean Michelle and Victory.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.